what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode of our
beyond omega level series where we talk
about the most powerful characters and
comics and today we're doing another
viewer requested episode and this one
comes to us from mocktackle i think it's
how you pronounce that who requested
that we cover david richards a character
whose name is really really boring but
who's ridiculously powerful so david
richards was created by jed winik and
mike mccon and first appeared in exiles
number 12 in 2002. now if you are not
familiar with the concept of the exiles
they were a team that was basically made
up of heroes from different universes
that basically fix broken realities and
directing all of this is an entity known
as the time broker now unbeknownst to
the exiles the time broker had basically
formed another team called weapon x and
this team is made up of alternate
reality versions of sabertooth storm
spider-man deadpool she-hulk and vision
so these two teams finally meet and at
this point in time the exiles roster is
made up of blink morph not the one from
x-men the animated series by the way
nocturne who's basically the daughter of
alternate versions of scarlet witch and
nightcrawler mimic and then sasquatch
keep in mind however that these are not
the main marvel universe versions of
these characters but ones from alternate
realities but regardless the exiles and
weapon x meet up and get called on a
mission to earth 2600 which is a world
where mutants are being eradicated by
sentinels much the same way as was done
in like the days of future past
storyline or bishop's timeline but on
earth 2600 much like the days of future
past reality itself franklin richards
the son of reed richards and susan storm
has a child with rachel summers the
daughter of cyclops and jean grey now on
earth 2600 franklin and rachel are both
dead and david is a six-year-old boy
seen as the last great hope for mutant
kind and is predicted to be the most
powerful being in the world when he
grows up so the exiles and weapon x work
together to infiltrate the sentinel
facility where david's being held and
they find that he's actually one of many
children being held in a detention camp
and amazingly enough they are able to
rescue david and the other children
quite easily suffering no casualties
along the way what they don't know
however is that their real mission was
not to simply rescue david but to kill
him and it's revealed that david would
indeed grow up to be immensely powerful
and would eventually free the planet
from the rule of the signals however due
to the fact that all he had ever known
was torture death and punishment he
would then replace the sentinels as the
world's oppressor and would enslave the
planet itself naturally the exiles
aren't really thrilled at the
proposition of having to take out a
six-year-old but weapon x the more
ruthless of the two teams is more than
happy to complete the mission because if
they don't none of them will get back to
their home dimensions so the two teams
battle with sabertooth defecting to the
exiles and then eventually blink
teleports the exiles far enough away to
save david's life and then sabertooth
vows to raise the kid as his own and
keep him from becoming the murderous
dictator that he seemed destined to
become so saber tooth stays behind and
raises david and the other kids which is
kind of a weird prospect to know that
like sabertooth is raising your child i
would kind of want to see that show the
adventures of sabretooth and friends
right like sabertooth the babysitter it
would just be kind of weird but blink
eventually finds her way back to him to
see what has become of the children just
in time for their attack on the last
sentinel stronghold in north america now
she senses something's wrong with david
when he probes her mind to evaluate
whether she's trustworthy but he
performs brilliantly in battle with
blink remarking that david is what you
would get if you rolled up professor x
magneto and the phoenix force all into
one entity which should give you a good
idea of how ridiculously powerful this
guy is now after the sentinels are
defeated david announces that they were
just a symptom of the earth's real
problem which is humans he then takes
over blink's mind and forces her to use
her powers to murder people by
teleporting them in half for two solid
days david's killing spree was then put
to an end when sabertooth took him by
surprise and ripped his heart from his
chest now david would eventually
resurrect himself but would not retain
any of his memories or his powers but in
the brief time he was around david
richards was extremely powerful as he
was born of two omega-level mutants now
like his mother david possesses
incredibly strong telepathic and
telekinetic abilities not only can he
read minds but he can take control of
the minds of others and force them to
act in accordance with his will and
against their own as we saw when he
forced blink to murder a bunch of people
he also possesses the ability to absorb
the powers of others and mimic whatever
powers they may possess and even amp
them up to higher levels for instance
blink was able to exceed the limitations
of her teleportation ability when david
was in control of her mind but what
really sets david apart is that he seems
to be able to manifest the phoenix force
at will now the phoenix force is one of
the most powerful forces in the marvel
universe and is the embodiment of all
life that has ever currently does or
will ever exist across the omniverse so
typically we've seen the phoenix force
take over a host such as jean grey or
rachel summers and basically use the
host to do some ridiculously powerful
things and in some cases like with jean
grey the phoenix force can actually
corrupt the person that is chosen as its
host regardless the fact that david
richards is able to summon the phoenix
force seemingly at will and without
having to serve as its host and the fact
that he is described as being professor
x magneto and the phoenix force all
rolled into one and it's not hard to
determine that he is way beyond omega
level granted we don't see minnie feetzy
pulls off because he's not around very
long in the comics all we really see is
him taking out 84 sentinels at once but
when we evaluate his potential we know
that he's capable of a whole lot more
and the fact that he is the son of
franklin richards who is probably one of
the most powerful reality warpers in all
of marvel comics suggests that maybe he
has reality warping abilities but we
haven't really been able to find any
concrete examples of him being able to
alter reality but yeah that's basically
david richards right we don't really see
him pop up outside of like that one
reality but it would be interesting to
see him at the height of his power so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end if there are any
characters you want to see post comments
down below and i will catch you all
later
peace